E
FINAL DAYS REALLY ARE.
>> THEY ARE VERY CRUCIAL, DIANE
GALLAGHER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS CNN POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT --
AND POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
STRATEGIST AL STEWART.
OUT, HOW WORRIED ARE WE ABOUT
REPUBLICANS THIS TUESDAY?
>> THEY'RE CONCERNED.
THAT'S WHY IT'S ALL HANDS ON
DECK FROM NOW THROUGH TUESDAY.
WE HAVE SENATORS TIM SCOTT, AND
ALSO JOHN KENNEDY FROM
LOUISIANA GOING THERE.
THEY'RE MAKING THE CASE MORE
ABOUT THE IMPETUS ON THIS.
OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE
SUPPORT OVER THE SENATE MAKING
THIS A 50/50 SENATE AS A PORT
--
AND WE'VE SEEN BIDEN CAMP, THE
VERY POPULAR GOVERNOR MAKING
THAT CASE.
THAT THIS IS CRUCIAL FOR AS
DIANE SAID, MAKING SURE WE HAVE
STRONG COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE'RE SEEING, HERSCHEL WALKER'S
FINAL POT, IS THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO ABOUT DOING.
THUS MAKING THIS ABOUT POLICY,
MAKING THIS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
RAPHAEL WARNOCK'S A RUBBER SNAP
FOR JOE BIDEN.
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT WARNOCK
CAMPAIGN IS DOING MORE PERSONAL
ATTACKS AGAINST HERSCHEL
WALKER.
LOOK, THIS IS ONE THAT'S DOWN
TO THE WIRE.
REPUBLICANS ARE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC.
THIS BOILS DOWN TO AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
CANDIDATE QUALITY.
HERSCHEL WALKER WASN'T THE
NUMBER ONE CHOICE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
BUT HE'S THE PERSON WE HAVE.
I DO ENCOURAGE ALL MY FELLOW
GEORGIANS, AND THE GEORGIA --
TO GET OUT THERE AND SUPPORT
HIM.
I >> SEE YOU IN THE GEORGIA
BULLDOG COLORS.
>> YES.
>> I MAKE THIS MORE ABOUT THE
POLICIES AS OPPOSED TO THE
PERSONAL ATTACKS IN THE
CANDIDATE.
>> APRIL, --
GABRIEL STERLING TOLD CNN WE
MAY NOT KNOW WHO WON THE RUNOFF
ON ELECTION DAY.
NOT THAT ANYONE WANTS TO HEAR
THAT RIGHT NOW.
BUT LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY.
>> WE'RE PREPARING FOR IT BEING
A VERY TIGHT RACE.
I ANTICIPATE WE MAY NOT KNOW ON
TUESDAY NIGHT, IT JUST REALLY
DEPENDS BECAUSE IT'S UP TO THE
VOTERS.
AND THEY'RE SHOWING UP IN
DROVES.
1,852,000 IS A RIDICULOUS
NUMBER.
THAT NO CONSULTANT I'VE TALKED,
A REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, OR
ELECTION --
THAT THIS EARLY.
>> APRIL, AT THE THE RESULTS
TAKE ALLOWED AND WE SEE ANOTHER
BREEDING GROUND FOR ELECTION
DENIERS AND CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, WHAT DO YOU?
THINK >> MOST DEFINITELY.
THEY'RE ALREADY THERE.
BUT YOU NEED TO REMEMBER, AT
1.8 MILLION ARE IN EARLY
VOTING.
HE SAID THAT WAS A RIDICULOUS
NUMBER.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER.
FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE FIRED
UP, JUST LIKE AL-ASSAD.
BUT WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT EARLY
ELECTIONS, EARLY VOTING IT
INTENDS TO BEAT DEMOCRATS.
BUT REPUBLICANS ARE PREPARED TO
GO ON ELECTION DAY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT MAY
TAKE DAYS, IT MAY TAKE HOURS,
IT MAY TAKE MINUTES.
WE DO NOT KNOW.
BUT WE DO KNOW FOR SURE, PEOPLE
ARE FIRED UP.
NOT JUST GEORGIA, BUT THE
NATION BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT
THAT GEORGIA HAS ON EVERYTHING
IN THE SENATE.
NOT ONLY THAT, I TALKED, JIM,
TO PEOPLE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMUNITY.
AND THEY SAID WHEN IT COMES TO
GEORGIA, I SAID LOOK, IF
HERSCHEL WALKER GETS A, CIVIL
RIGHTS WILL NOT BE AS --
AS IT COULD BE.
IF WARNOCK WOULD MAKE A.
THEY FEEL THAT CIVIL RIGHTS
EQUITY AND INCLUSION WILL BE A
PROBLEM FOR HERSCHEL WALKER,
AND WHAT --
>> ALICE, LET'S TURN TO SOME
OTHER POLITICAL NEWS, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP I'M SURE YOU
SAW THIS ONE ON TRUTH SOCIAL.
CALL FOR THE TERMINATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION TO FACILITATE A
NEW ELECTION AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
OR AN IMMEDIATE RETURN TO
OFFICE AS THE RIGHTFUL WINNER
AS WE KNOW THIS IS NOT GONNA
HAPPEN.
BUT HERE ARE SOME REACTIONS
FROM REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHOEVER THE REPUBLICANS
DON'T PICKUP AND FALL BEHIND
EVEN IF IT'S DONALD TRUMP AND
HE'S CALLED FOR SUSPENDING THE
CONSTITUTION,, AGAIN I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A BIG FEEL THAT I
THINK DONALD TRUMP'S GONNA
CLEAR AT THE FEEL LIKE HE DID
--
>> I'M ASKING, IF HE'S THE
NOMINEE WILL YOU SUPPORT HIM?
>> I'LL SUPPORT WHOEVER THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE IS.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK AT THIS
POINT THAT HE'LL BE ABLE TO GET
THERE BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER QUALITY CARROTS
OUT.
THEY'RE >> ALL ELECTED LEADERS
SWEAR TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S CALLING FOR IT SUSPENSION
IS THAT DISQUALIFYING
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES?
>> IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
CONSISTENT.
IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE
OATH WE ALL TAKE.
>> LET ME READ YOU HOW LIZ
CHENEY REACTED TO ALL THIS.
DONALD TRUMP BELIEVE WE CAN
TERMINATE RULES, REGULATIONS,
AND ARTICLES EVEN THOSE FOUND
--
2020 ELECTION.
THAT WAS HIS VIEW ON JANUARY
SIX.
IT REMAINS WITH YOU TODAY.
NO HONEST PRESIDENT CAN DENY
THAT TRUMP'S ANATOMY OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
ALICE, ARE WE REALLY GONNA SEE
THE PARTY GET TWISTED INTO A
PRETZEL BY TRUMP ONCE AGAIN ON
THESE KINDS OF QUESTIONS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WE'RE SEEING NOW, THERE'S A
CHOICE.
BACK IN ACCESS HOLLYWOOD DONALD
TRUMP WAS A NOMINEE, IN CRISIS
AFTER CRISIS, AND NOT SMART
STATEMENT ON TRUMP'S BEHALF.
HE'S BEEN THE ONLY CHOICE.
NOW WE HAVE OTHER CHOICES.
HE'S GOING AGAINST A BIG FIELD
OF REPUBLICANS IN 2024.
THAT ARE CONSISTENT
CONSERVATIVES.
THERE ARE IRRATIONAL
CONSERVATIVES, COMMON SENSE
CONSERVATIVES.
AND THEY'RE NOT AS DIVISIVE AS
HAM.
I HATE TO INFORM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, THE CONSTITUTION
DOESN'T LIKE A SPOUSE, YOU
CAN'T JUST GET RID OF IT WHEN
IT NO LONGER SUTURE PURPOSES.
THE CONSTITUTION IS HERE TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL
AMERICANS.
IT'S NOT THERE TO CHANGE THE
PAST ELECTION OF A SELF SERVING
AMERICAN.
AND HE IS WRONG ON THIS, THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS.
AND I GUARANTEE YOU JIM, THE
MORE YOU ASKED CONSERVATIVES
AND REPUBLICANS ABOUT THE
STATEMENT.
THEY WILL SAY THIS IS NOT
RIGHT.
THEY'RE GONNA SEPARATE
THEMSELVES FROM THIS KIND OF
STATEMENTS.
>> ALICE, THE CONSTITUTION IS
NOT LIKE THE BUFFET AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
YOU CAN'T GET PAST THE ITEMS
YOU DON'T LIKE.
>> --
APRIL, LET ME ASK YOU THAT.
THE CONSTITUTION ISN'T LIKE THE
MAR-A-LAGO BUFFET, YOU CAN'T
SKIP PAST THE ITEMS YOU DON'T
LIKE.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> APRIL, CAN YOU HEAR ME?
LOOKS LIKE WE MAY HAVE LOST
APRIL'S AUDIO.
ALICE, THIS IS GONNA BE A
PROBLEM FOR THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADER, KEVIN
MCCARTHY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR YET WHETHER OR
NOT HE'S GONNA HAVE THE VOTES
TO BECOME THE NEXT SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
HE SAYS HE PLANS TO READ THE
ENTIRE CONSTITUTION FROM THE
HOUSE ON THE FIRST DAY OF THE
NEW CONGRESS.
BUT YET MCCARTHY IS YET TO
CONDEMN TRUMP FOR CALLING TO
TERMINATE THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
>> IT IS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AREN'T GONNA BE
PROACTIVE AND COME OUT AND
DENOUNCED LUDICROUS STATEMENT.
IF ASKED, I GUARANTEE, A JAM,
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THERE IS NO SPACE IN
AMERICAN POLITICS FOR THIS.
KEVIN MCCARTHY IS IN A VERY
TOUGH BATTLE, MAYBE THE BATTLE
OF IS LIVE IN TERMS OF --
AND HE'S GONNA BE GOING AGAINST
OTHER REPUBLICANS THAT ARE PRO
TRUMP HE NEEDS TO THREAD THAT
NEEDLE IN TERMS OF STANDING UP
FOR THE CONSTITUTION AND FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WITHOUT POKING THE BEAR AND
POKING AGAINST THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SPEAKING AGAINST HIM AS
SPEAKER.
I GUARANTEE IF HE WAS ASKED, HE
DENOUNCED THAT STATEMENT.
HE'S TRYING TO DO WHAT HE CAN
TO MAINTAIN HIS ATTEMPT TO GET
THE NECESSARY VOTES TO BE
TERMINATION OF THEFOR THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
I KNOW HE DOES THIS FROM TIME
TO TIME, TRYING TO JAM UP PRESS
COVERAGE FOR WHAT APPEARS TO BE
A FALTERING RUN FOR THE
PRESIDENCY ONE MORE TIME.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU CAN'T
IGNORE WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A
THREAT TO THE CONSTITUTION THAT
HE IS EXPRESSING.
>> JIM, WE COVERED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
FACTUALLY, HE'S KNOWN TO HAVE
BROKEN THE RULE OF LAW WHILE IN
OFFICE.
HE NOW BEING INVESTIGATED BY
THE STATE OF GEORGIA, OF NEW
YORK, JANUARY 6TH, AND OTHERS,
BECAUSE HE HAS BROKEN THE RULE
OF LAW.
HE'S GOING INTO THIS ATTEMPT TO
BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AGAIN IN HIS 2024
EFFORTS.
IT IS A WEEKEND CANDIDATE,
BECAUSE OF THE PAST, BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING AGAIN TO
TRY TO WIN BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY, ANY WAY THAT HE CAN.
LOOK AT WHAT HE DID ONCE AGAIN,
LET'S TALK ABOUT GEORGIA.
THEY TRIED TO HAVE THE NUMBERS
CHANGED IN GEORGIA WHEN IT CAME
TO THE FINAL COUNT OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE VOTED.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE, IT'S
JUST ANOTHER NEWS STORY ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP TRYING TO WIN THE
OVAL OFFICE BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
ALICE IS RIGHT, THERE ARE A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T HAVE
THE STOMACH FOR THIS.